qu'est-ce que tu fais toi tu es pas
équipé tu sors tu vas t'équiper tu
reviens tu vas être équipé tu reviens
allez vas-y mon bébé et tu m'enlèves
cette vilaine veste
après je te dis la vérité je t'ai
toujours tout dit non ça va pas du tout
j'ai vraiment juste pour te faire
plaisir parce que c'est joli bah je te
dis la vérité frère ça va pas
je te dis pour toi
va descendre les poubelles quelque chose
mais
c'est pas pour l'antenne c'est pas pour
l'antenne vas-y bébé vas-y va te changer
fais-toi beau et reviens dans une heure
ça c'est réglé bon il est 18h40 de
l'échirer en étant direct merci d'être
là merci d'être aussi nombreux j'ai
plein de choses à vous dire déjà merci
merci d'être là vous
vous a été convoqué
il est là-bas très bien ça frérot il est
venu avec sa meuf j'espère
c'est un pote de paddle ah il est plus
fort que vous non je pense pas
tu te sens plus fort que moi tu te sens
plus fort que moi
[Applaudissements]
j'avais un pote dans le public tu me
donneras ton palmarès c'est plus gros
que le mien tu peux faire merci
[Rires]
c'est laquelle des deux
chérie merci en tout cas d'être là aussi
il y a une nouvelle qui nous a rejoint
la ferme bordel
non mais sans déconner tu vois pas
content
oui pourquoi je te le dis la veste non
l'attitude
j'en ai rien à
demain je te mets sur France Inter avec
Sofia
et en plus je te raconterai un truc qui
m'est arrivé ce matin
correspondrait
calme-toi mon chéri
on a des bonnes nouvelles déjà on a eu
un record d'audience sur TPMP people
samedi
je vais vous dire et je vais vous dire
Mathieu il m'a envoyé un petit mot que
d'ailleurs je vais l'embrasser pour le
remercier ce qui m'a il m'a envoyé un
mot vraiment un très beau joli mot mon
chéri et toi non mais vraiment mon chéri
je suis fier de lui je suis fier de lui
je suis fier de lui et oui une pointe à
plus d'un million d'eux ça me dit samedi
soir ça commence à il me dit non c'est
nul je dis non
plus de 1 million de cent mille
personnes sur TPMP
c'est très gentil bigari c'est un mec de
TPMP je t'ai dit est-ce que je peux
l'avoir un petit peu ça peut brouiller
les marques tu mets une ici sa tête et
qui veut bien bien sûr merci Jean-Marie
merci
il m'a écrit
un texto j'ai versé une petite larme
c'est un amour ce mec là tu es heureux
de cette émission là ça cartonne ouais
heureux de voir que
voilà tout ce qu'on s'est dit tous les
deux ça peut aussi
la vérité parce qu'on se dit tout avec
Mathieu un jour je l'ai appelé et j'ai à
sa naissance un samedi soir et je vais
je lui ai dit des je lui ai dit des
choses sur son animation sur sa carrière
te taire 30 minutes tu m'écouter et tu
veux devenir un meilleur animateur et
j'ai rendez-vous et je te dis c'est
comme botas qui a écouté Hamilton quoi
je vais te dire comment gagner 2/10
autour non non mais c'est un amour non
non mais c'est pas vrai déjà il a un
énorme talent Mathieu je l'ai toujours
dit ici et c'est vrai que tellement en
fait je vais vous dire je crois
tellement lui et je croyais tellement
lui que j'ai dit il faut que j'essaie de
discussion avec lui donc je l'ai appelé
je lui ai dit tout seul et je lui ai dit
ce que je pensais de de de lui je lui ai
dit que je trouvais je trouvais qu'il
avait un potentiel extraordinaire pour
moi le plus gros potentiel de la télé
actuellement et je lui ai dit voilà les
deux petits de trois petits choses que
je voyais à l'antenne parce que quand à
l'antenne tu peux pas tu vois pas donc
voilà moi j'ai un regard extérieur et
donc je lui ai dit voilà et je lui ai
dit tu vas tu vas tu vas tu vas tout
déchirer et là aujourd'hui quand je vois
les scores je me dis on a bien fait de
qui m'a marqué dans ce que tu m'as dit
et la psy aussi ce qu'on fait beaucoup
de travail sur moi-même mais je pense
qu'avant tu faisais de la télé pour toi
fais de la télé pour les autres voilà
juste soit toi-même et sois généreux tu
verras c'est sûr et c'est vrai que
toi-même à l'antenne tu rigoles j'avais
fait pour les autres parce que moi
Mathieu dans la dans la vie il m'a
toujours fait rire c'est-à-dire qu'on a
fait des on a pris les fous rires
ensemble incroyable c'est vrai quand on
était parti on est parti à Las Vegas on
était
tout tout et c'est vrai que à long terme
parfois il je trouvais qu'il jouait un
peu l'animateur il n'était pas lui-même
et là en ce moment à chaque fois que je
le regarde il me tue de rire à l'antenne
ce que c'est c'est Mathieu comme il est
dans la vie et c'est vrai que ça et les
gens se sont pas trompés puisque ça
cartonne de plus en plus et ça va encore
monter tu vas voir et l'année prochaine
tu vas tu vas faire un million de
moyenne tu verras je te l'aurais je te
l'aurais
[Applaudissements]